- You might've been hearing
that there are major changes
to copyright law coming
as a result of the new
appropriations bill.
And that's because it's true.
The new appropriations
bill has two main changes.
One, it makes it a felony to
do certain kinds of streaming.
That's not that big of a change
because lots of copyright infringement
is considered a felony, it
just brings streaming in line
with the rest of those infringements.
And the other is creating
small claims court
for copyright law.
This could go both ways
with an uptick in copyright trolling
and people having to
pay as much as $30,000
plus attorney's fees.
On the other hand,
you might have smaller
creators getting remuneration
for people using their
copyrighted material.
I'm gonna have to think about this.
It's complicated and I'll
probably do a full video on it.
But if it wants some holiday cheer,
check out the video I did
on all the law's broken
in "Christmas Vacation,"
and I'll see you in court.